Here's the strategy that I would suggest. There's probably a couple of different ways to do this.
We could take the original graph that we know there is some length l path, simple path from U to V
and what we can do is for each edge in the graph say, well, what if we delete that edge?
Is there still a path? And if the answer is yes, then we just leave it deleted.
But if the answer is no, that we've now actually broken a path from the last path from U to V
of length at least l in G, then we need to leave it in there.
We keep repeating this until all the edges have been considered
and all that's left at the end will be the simple path.
Why, because if there's any edges in there that's not on the simple path then
we can delete it and there still is a simple path
and certainly we can't delete any of the ones on that simple path and still have it work.
What's left is exactly what we need.
Here's my attempted datas Python code, so again,
we check first to make sure that there really is such a path and if there isn't,
then we just quit before we try to find it, but if there is, so somewhere in there, the path exists,
what we're going to do is run through all the edges, so node1 in G, look at all the neighbors.
Look at node2 which is the neighbor of node1. So now node1, node2 is an edge in the graph
and we're going to break the link. I probably should've mentioned that earlier
but there is actually a break-the-link piece of code int he skeleton that I gave you.
In graph G, get rid of the edge from node1 to node2.
You can do that in constant time and then we ask,
is it the case that there is still a long and simple path, we ask for the decision.
Is there a long and simple path in G from U to V of length l?
And if the answer is no, if there's not such a path then we need to put that edge
back in the graph; otherwise, we just leave it out.
We'll repeat this for all the nodes, all the edges, and then we're basically done.
All that's left in G is exactly the simple path and now we have to read it out.
It's a little bit messier than I thought it would be, but it's definitely doable.
You could run that graph search on this graph and that would work
Because all that's left is the path that you want but another way to do it
that's more specific to this case is we start off building our path from U,
we're going to have a variable node which is a particular point in the chain.
In the variable next which is the next point in the chain
and we start that off with whatever is the neighbor of U.
Notice there can only be one neighbor of U because all that's left is the simple path from U to V.
Okay, all right, so now, we say as long as that next node that we're looking for isn't V,
we append next to the path so far so we have the first two steps and now we're at a new node,
this node next is going to have two neighbors, one is going to be the node we just came from, node.
And the other one is going to be a new node that we haven't considered yet.
To figure out which one it is, what I did is I just pulled the two of them off.
I said let the nextnext0 be one of those neighbors and nextnext1 be the other.
If nextnext0 is the node we just came from, then we're going to move one step along the chain.
Node gets next and next gets nextnext1, the one that we haven't visited and; otherwise,
next gets nextnext0, the one we haven't visited.
When that loop is all through, then next is V, the very last step on the path
and which add that into our path and return it.